herrschaften ruhe bitte nach bachblüten
chirurgie und rektalen brauchen wenn wir
uns heute einer anderen alternativen
heilmethode zu der homöopathie
das griechisch und bedeutet die lehre
vom ähnlichen leiden also doktor
bekloppt plus patient bekloppt fleisch
homöopathie es geht der hypo kroatischem
einheit behandelt den patient schneller
als er von selbst gesund wird das
prinzip der homöopathie ist ähnliches
mit ähnlichem zu heilen
sie leiden unter kopfschmerzen kein
problem ein schlag mit einer dachlatte
ins gemächt und der schmerz im kopf ist
nur noch eine dumpfe erinnerung
der patient hat immer recht und möchten
nicht mit schlauen bayerischer
diagnostik vom arroganten schulmediziner
belästigt werden wenn sie das dann
wissen und zerdrückte biene und andere
dinge zu sich nehmen wollen dann kann
ich sie nicht davon abhalten das war ja
auch wohl noch schöner
gerade das fressen von platt gefloppten
bienen und wespen gehört er zu den
grundfreiheiten unserer demokratie und
überhaupt was weiß denn schon die lügen
medizin
wir wissen ja überhaupt noch gar nicht
ob es das sage ich jetzt mal ganz
ketzerisch als virus protestant und als
protestant hobbs das masernvirus
überhaupt gibt das hat ja noch nie einer
gesehen eben zb
das wichtigste prinzip der homöopathie
ist die unendliche verdünnung beispiel
einer pinkl dem freibad ins becken
keiner hat's gemerkt doch sobald es mir
einer erzählt schmecke ich sogar die
piste obwohl ich gar nicht mehr im
wasser binden der glaube an die wirkung
ist nicht nur die halbe sondern die
ganzen mittel zur ehrenrettung der
homöopathie muss man allerdings sagen
placebos töten weniger menschen als
echte medikamente bei der herstellung
werden zwar auch giftige substanzen wie
erdöl oder arsen verwendet substanzen
von denen einem normalerweise das eigene
auspuffrohre um die ohren fliegt aber
diese substanzen werden dann vom homo
schamanen bis unter die nachweisgrenze
verdünnt das nennt sich seltsamerweise
die potenzierung dabei wird die substanz
mit einem alkohol wasser gemisch erst
stark verdünnt und dann vermittelt
dieses verschütteten geschieht von hand
getreu den vorschriften des homöopathie
erfinders samuel hahnemann
wenn sie lieber zuschauer also gerade
merken dass eine grippe im anflug ist
verschütten sich doch einfach rein und
zwar von hand streng nach den
vorschriften von samuel hahnemann dem
alten hühner venture macht aber spaß in
diesem sinne den segen der nach
[Musik]